ti-83 it doesn't have the ability to
input a different bass aside from log
and natural log LG and Ln over here and
the ti-84 this one over here you can
change the base and I'm going to show
you how to do that so say for example
you want to find out log base 3 of 7
what you want to do is you want to go
over here to math okay and you want to
arrow down okay it's in this first
column letter a log base so I'm going to
press ENTER and you can see you can
change the base here log base 3 okay I'm
an arrow over of 7 and enter so you can
see that's one point seven seven now if
your calculator doesn't have that
ability what you can do is you can use
the change of base formula and the way
the change of base formula works is you
pick a new base like log base ten or a
natural log which is log base E and you
put this argument seven in the numerator
and you put the base in this case three
in the denominator and you just do the
log of seven over the log of three so
that's what we'll do right here now and
I'll show you that as well so we've got
log of seven log of seven divided by the
log of three and you can see we get the
same value one point seven seven you can
also do the natural log of seven divided
by the natural log of three and again
the same result so you can see if